Let me show you the code to
do the same thing in numpy.
And then what's refer you with once we get
the syntax of not Pi I'll switch over to
talk about types of matrices.
And then once but then we'll we're ready to talk about Led composition.
So I'm going to open.
new notebook
Matrix operations
IP y
in b
So now what I need to do is go back up here and do.
Gaussian elimination, but with no pie. So what I'm
gonna first do is import numpy.
import
numpy
as NP
and then I'm going to use S to represent my
system
Cuba great question would be a scorpion are using it's called Jupiter.
So if you want to do jupyter notebook whether I
recommend this versus installing Jupiter notebook separately
if you click on the extension the
Extension icon is for boxes.
Search for Jupiter.
do
better
and all you need to do is Click.
Install restart vs code and you're good to go.
Now the reason I have to wait a while for Notebook to
open up is because I have different python versions. I
shouldn't uninstall them. But otherwise for you should be straightforward.
I've attached instructions on the dashboard.
Or vs code so go to the instructions and you can have the same
setup.
Okay, so I'm gonna have S stand
for my system of in a
qualities here. So we have
two rows
with
and 3,000 again. I'm gonna leave out the
10 to the power 4 part
and this is 200.
Okay, so and of course, I'm going to turn this into a numpy array because
I want to perform.
Matrix operations using numpy
Okay.
So let's begin.
Now the first thing I did was swap Row
2 and Row 1. I'm just gonna do that up here. I'm just going to
swap them around like so
okay.
now
if I want to
subtract row
two from Row 1
I would do it this way. So we have
row.
And of course we have to remember that we count from zero in in
programming. So if I
want to say the first row, I would have to put in 0
and if I want to say row two two minus one,
that's one.
Okay, so if I want to subtract these two.
I'll come back to the difference method. But yeah, if
you want to subtract the second rule.
From the first row so subtract the second
of the first row.
We type in the first row minus second row and then it will
subtract the second row from the first row.
And then if I want to replace the first row, I'm going
to go that's
sub z s of 0
Equals well that difference.
And to see the result I'm going to Simply print.
Yes, so let me run this again.
by print s
you can see we have done just that.
100 zero 1000 100
okay, and I can continue this way. So right
now I need to subtract Row 1
from Row 2 and then plug it into.
row to okay, so that's I mean this was
this was supposed to be
our underscore to
our underscore
to
just make me careful here.
Okay.
So this I'm just going to copy this bit.
So I'm going to subtract Row 1 from Row
2.
now addition, of course in Python it has
three
applications you can use it to add two.
Numeric data types, so intent float, you can
use it to concatenate two strings together you can use
it to merge to list together.
But I'm just trying to make this look as I'm trying to
make the python code look as much.
You know to make it as close to what we
see in there and in the market file and the math.
So here I want to subtract.
the second row from the first row
and then replace the second row.
And there we have it.
And then you get the idea right then we would multiply the
first row by whatever 100 and until
we get to this point.
Until we get X and Y.
Okay.
So I won't finish this this part you
can you can do this on your but I hope you get the idea now.
So what I'm going to do from this point I always is
show you
what?
inverse Matrix identity matrices do
to any any Square Matrix
and then we can see it's output.
every stop of the way